und es geht offenbar immer noch
grausamer im ukraine krieg schauen sie
auf diese brutalen setzte der russischen
regierung in diesem fall der russischen
botschaft in großbritannien sie schreibt
as of militanten verdienen die
hinrichtung aber nicht durch ein
erschießungskommando sondern durch
erhängen denn sie sind keine echten
soldaten sie verdienen einen erniedrigen
den tod dass die worte der russischen
botschaft in großbritannien das ist eine
neue dimension noch mal eine neue
grausame dimension in diesem ukraine
krieg denn es ist nichts anderes als die
aufforderung einer offiziellen stelle
der russischen regierung ein
kriegsverbrechen zu begehen
kriegsverbrechen an den asus kämpfern
das sind auch die männer die wochenlang
in diesem maß auf stahlwerk hier in
mario pohl im osten der ukraine gekämpft
haben dort wo der krieg also so
besonders erbarmungslos und brutal war
diese überlebenden kämpfer aus dem
stahlwerk die wollen die russen also nun
so brutal ermorden lassen dazu ruft die
russische botschaft in großbritannien
auf und dabei sind unsere reporter
weiter tag für tag in der ukraine
unterwegs in diesem krieg um ihnen das
ganze bild dieses krieges zu zeigen
unser bild kriegsreporter björn stritzel
ist derzeit mit mörser einheiten
unterwegs mit mörser einheiten der
ukrainischen armee
jetzt schlagen sie zurück mörser raketen
abgefeuert auf russische stellungen sie
donnern richtung ist der vielleicht
wichtigsten stadt für den russischen
nation
petja und sein team versuchen die
versorgungslinien der russischen
invasoren zu stören und erste erfolge
deuten sich an nachdem sie russischen
munitionsdepot zerstört haben gibt es
weniger raketeneinschläge bild-reporter
bier und schnitzel ist an der front
begleitet das ukrainische mehrzad ihn im
kampfeinsatz
dann kommt die durchsage per funk
es geht los
seit jahren sein team springen auflaufen
zu ihren fahrzeugen
nach einigen kilometern fahrt in
richtung der russischen stellungen
erreichen sie eine lichtung das gebüsch
bietet sich schutz gegen russische
drohen wir sind in der ost ukraine an
der front nahe beisammen und begleitet
hier gerade zwei moerser teams die mit
ihren 82 mm lesern gleich versuchen wir
an die russische stellung unter feuer zu
legen das ist ein wenig riskant für
diese teams immer deshalb weil sie
relativ nah heranfahren müssen danach
sich schnell wieder zurückziehen um eben
dem russischen gegen feuer zu entkommen
momentan warten die beiden teams noch
darauf dass die ziele bestätigt werden
ihre mäuse sind jetzt in position
gebracht und dann geht es auch gleich
los blitzschnell bauen die soldaten zwei
moerser auflegen die granaten bereit
dann die nächste durchsage ein
ukrainischer kommandant gibt die
zielkoordinaten durch
während das letzte chance noch in der
luft ist warum die männer eilig zusammen
verladen die moerser in die fahrzeuge
und rasen wieder weg bevor der russische
gegenschlag aus und
bereiten sich dann auf den nächsten
angriff vor
[Musik]